you don't look at them as iconic
characters I mean they refer to them as
that if they become that you're just
doing a day you're on a day-to-day
running it having a good time and trying
to trying to make it
[Music]
work I like a lot about snake he's an
escape artist is really what he is and
he's doomed to never be able to escape
the one thing he wants to escape from
and that's himself I'm not a full pisin
call me snake he's got this equal amount
of psychosis and survivability they go
together I like that about snake or at
least I felt that that was true about
him we started out doing some stuff that
ended up not being in the movie was a
train station sequence sort of
establishing the character of snake and
he had a partner and got shot and snake
actually ran back to help him they
caught them it was a redeeming quality
is what we were showing there John garer
decided correctly so that snake didn't
have any redeeming qualities so I only
cared about you know pleasing John and
hopefully trying to capture something
you know that was going to fit into his
vision we had done Elvis together and we
just automatically sort of had a
quick language amongst ourselves John
said you know go you know see what you
come up with thinking about that
character it was futuristic stuff you
know the black and white was much more
interesting than green fatigues as if
the war had taken place in a sort of a
burnt out winter area so it was all
black and white but then I got to
thinking about this sake and I thought
it was you know a cobra with its tail
going down his because there was going
to be this one scene where he's going to
be in the arena fighting kind have
thought it was appropriate to put the
tattoo right on him right up front just
took the tail
and let it go
south after we did a couple of takes of
the first in that train sequence he came
over he came over he was whispered and
he this character is great and
he was like yeah cuz I hadn't really
didn't really know how I was going to
sound like kind of got look and feel and
be but the sound of snake you me and
Fresno Bob you know what they did to Bob
H you want to see him sprayed all over
that map baby where's the president I
mean when there was LE van CLE was
playing the role of Hal and so because
of that for me I guess it just kicked
off that sort of whole leave Van Cleave
Clint e W Western World I just always
felt snake was only talking to himself
he was never really talking to anybody
you going to kill me now
snake I'm too
tired maybe later it's a video game
series called middle Gear Solid it was
rumored that there a character in the
game that's inspired by snake p and ask
you to do the voice over well it's like
look I you know I'm pretty lazy by
Nature remember there have been many
different times when people you know
wanted to do something I don't know I'm
a movie guy you have to understand
understand it from my point of view
whether it's Elvis or snake pisin or
Jack Burton or RJ mccre that was that
project that was that thing you get into
that mindset you you create that you
want to make that world happen just like
I used to do interviews when Elvis was
coming out and they would say come on do
a little Elvis for us you know it's like
I it doesn't it doesn't work that way
you don't just slide in and out of Elvis
you you you you go to work on it you
refine it and then you do it and you get
paid for that I come from a different
era wasn't interested in
expanding financially off of something
that we had created or that I had
created in terms of a character and I
get business people sure or we could we
could do this with that we could do this
with that or we could do this with that
you know and then I look at it and
that's not written by
John that that's that's not that doesn't
smell right John's not here to do this
with why why am I not going to do that
let's go do something new let's go do
something fresh let's go create another
iconic character rather than saying what
can we bleed off of this iconic
character you know you don't look at
them as iconic characters I mean they
refer to them as that if they become
that you're just doing a day you're on a
day-to-day running it having a good time
and trying to trying to make it
[Music]
work anyone messes with me in the whole
Camp
goes come on child burn me John on my
head been talking sometimes we'd talk
about what he was doing next or what I
was doing next whatever we got to
talking about what he was doing next
this project called the thing he was
trying to figure out who to cast in the
character of mccre we you know once in a
while hey how about so and so and he'd
go yeah maybe no you know my best friend
brother-in-law at the time Larry Franco
was producing it with John and then
finally one day I think Larry said it to
me first because it was sort of like a
hint like a warning I think John wants
is maybe going to talk to you about
playing that part so I said I don't know
is it a monster movie or
is a horror film what is it John said no
this is a this is from the book who goes
there he said yeah the thing was a it
was a movie 20 years what what 30 years
ago but I'm not doing that he said no
I'm I'm doing a movie about paranoia I
know I'm
human and if you were all these things
then you just attack me right now so
some of you are still human well we were
in two places primarily we were in hder
Alaska right across the street from St
British Columbia so we're working up on
a glacier 26 Mi up pretty exciting you
could look down 3,000 ft and see a bunch
of trucks down there he said so just
going to work was kind of fun we were in
Universal Studios on the refrigerated
set they wanted snow of course on the
set if you went above 28 29 degrees
inside it would start to kind of melt
and and they didn't we didn't want that
we all just sort of lived in this
thing basically Monday through Saturday
kind of reminded me of the set of backra
where we were in these fires these
man-made fires you know but we got so
used to the cold when you went inside
you take your jackets off and stuff and
you in your T-shirt it was 28 degrees in
there and you were like know you're
coming inside to warm up you know it was
a pretty cold
[Music]
environment I went into wardrobe and you
know because of the other things we've
done I sort of did it with my self just
sort of came up with stuff and then show
it to John you like it you know like and
when I was in there I noticed sitting
over on this chair by itself was this
enormous sombrero and finally at some
point I said to the to the Wardrobe
person what's what's to do with a
sombrero they said oh that's your hat I
saiding wearing that hat it's insane
what you talking about no and they said
well John's already been shooting some
stuff with it I said what he said yeah
it's established I said that hat is
established with what you're flying the
helicopters they've already got some
helicopter shots but I went oh come on I
need a character to actually hang my hat
on and I I said that's the Hat I never
loved the sun I like no no no I think
it's perfect I think it's perfect
there's a lot of things sometimes that
somebody else sees that you I you don't
see you have to be open for these things
you know that one's a tough one because
that's you know it's just it's just you
wearing this big ass goofy thing on your
head but you see that's where John
that's where John had no fear because he
knew how he was going to shoot it and I
started laughing at it and saying yeah
he's he's he's a drunk he doesn't give a
so he's got that Sombrero
[Music]
on John was never quite satisfied with
the last scene his main thing was he
didn't want to do two hours take the
audience on a ride for two hours and
bring him back to square one when you're
doing a movie you don't know what you
got you kind of in general know what you
got but you don't know exactly how this
is going to go together and what's going
to come out of it of course John did
almost all the time because you
understand you know he's unlike most
guys he he doing the music too
interestingly enough the thing was the
first time he didn't do the music all
the music and he had Annie Omar con do
it many many years later if you watch
the two movies back to back quent
Tarantino had anyo do his music for
hateful eight right off of the thing but
the last scene what we talked about a
lot we D out little different versions
of what do you think of that what do you
think of that go back and forth and we
finally got said John there I don't know
I know you don't want to come back
square one but it's kind of what it is
we don't even know if we're real we
don't even know we don't know we don't
know I don't think the audience can
figure it out I think that's what makes
the thing great is you don't know what
if this already happened are you you how
would you know and it all LED itself
down to what I fin said go ahead it was
the last line I just said I said I think
it's just like why don't we just just
sit it for a while see what happens they
could figure a way to kill each other at
exactly the same time I think maybe
that's the next step there I forget who
it was I was talking to the just the
other day it say he and his brother they
when the moment's right where were you
child where were you
child I like that that's iconic to have
somebody be able to hold on to that for
all these years and that just speaks to
me in a hundred different ways that to
me was John and maybe his absolute Peak
as of a director
that's really good film
[Music]
making oh my God Tombstone is about a
family you know family of people that
lived during a time when organized crime
was being formed in the United United
States and it happened to be in the west
and it happened to be those group of
cowboys coming from a Illinois coming
from the East a sort of a Quaker world
that's why they look the way they look
more the clothes they wore the hats
especially tombstone in terms of
westerns really was really exciting and
different a wonderful script written by
Kevin jar he drew most most of what he
wrote from periodicals and magazines and
stuff I talked to him a lot about it he
had this great way of
of understanding how these people spoke
and lived which I'd never seen before in
a western reading Tombstone the first
page said forget everything you have
ever read or seen about westerns it's
untrue and then afterwards it you know
it continued to show you that these
people in Tombstone were dressed to the
nin they showed their wealth coming into
a new town they needed to know you were
a man of substance a good businessman a
good
entrepreneur someone they could depend
on someone who was successful it was
these things that I found in Tombstone
to be be the things that you wanted to
learn about from the audience's point of
view how they spoke and why they spoke
that way one of my favorite things about
Tombstone when I read it I said man this
is really great screen place during the
middle of the conversation they all
everybody stopped and they looked up and
they started to applaud and that's what
people used to do when it was a full
moon they'd look up and see a beautiful
full moon and they just applaud and that
was their entertainment men of that time
were completely different people than
Now American men
and those American men were coming from
Europe and places from all over the
world and here was this group of men who
were figuring some things out and saying
hey we get this together we can run this
show and there's not much anybody can do
about
it well
well how the hell are you quiet I am
rolling now it's being considered one of
the great westerns ever made so I'm
happy about that often people say that
is the number one W I can't say that but
I like hearing that and and more and
more people are saying that now the
impact of the movie well I give that to
one story and I don't mean to say this
as in any way I put down although there
were certain people involved Kevin cner
not being one of them Kevin being a good
guy but there were other people involved
with that that were not good guys to me
once I said hey how about if we do this
and that maybe we could do some things
together I said I could kill you and
yours and you could kill me mine this
one individual said oh we're going to
kill a lot of people in werb and there
were some people standing around me and
it was just such a slap in the face and
I thought you buddy I'm going to
take you on full force full frontal
nudity let's go you're now going to run
into Wyatt her those two movies came out
fairly close to each other Wyatt her and
and Tombstone great things about both
but there's one undeniable thing you
named me another Western where you can
recall as much of the dialogue as people
can recall from Tombstone it's not even
close much more so than any other
Western that's undeniable I didn't think
you had it in you I'm your huckle be if
you're asking me if it was great working
with Val Kilmer who played Doc Holiday
on Tombstone the answer is absolutely in
those days especially you know when you
were working with people you get them
sometimes at the end of the show you get
gifts or trade gifts it's not mandatory
it's not something that you know you've
got to do it's or that they've got to do
and so I asked my
driver to uh see if could get a hold of
uh Val's holster and gun and hat and
chair with with his name on the back
take a picture and then in that picture
I wanted to have this thing it's the end
of the show where and it's been a battle
and we've all you know gotten through it
very well and I give Val this present
and he looks at me and he turns to his
driver and he says give it to me because
what I had gotten valve was a
plot at Boot Hill what Val had gotten me
was a an acre of land overlooking Boot
Hill doc holiday is all about death but
why it's all about life it's in that
last scene just looked at each other
well I guess that pretty much says it
all thanks for always being there doc
there's been a lot of things written
about Tombstone that are just so even
books that I just look at them people
have no concept even people who are
working on the show don't even know and
then never will every movie every show
is difficult to do it's generally going
to be a collaboration trust is going to
be either earned or found or not like
any other movie it's a miracle that it
gets made finding solutions to problems
was a constant on Tombstone the
difficulties uh that we were able to Fig
to figure out solutions to you know all
that matters is that it got done and
that the impact that the original
screenplay
promised yeah we got about 90% of
[Music]
that fair lady your chariot awaits
you've been e dropping eeve dropping and
can't help but here I think I belong in
a latter category Quenton is funny I
like his way and it's had fun every time
we work together I I appreciate every
time he wants me to work with him and
he's completely unique one of the
reasons Quenton Tarantino got into
making movies is because of John
Carpenter I mean I know that from the
horse's mouth John's more reserved in
his humor and in his style Quenton is
very very outgoing
but there's a lot of similarities too
and what's driving their mojo on making
a movie it's not like a director who's
searching for a vision they've got it in
their head and it's just a matter of
them having the freedom to say I like
that I like that like that don't like
that don't like you know they they're
it's easy for them I remember something
quen said one time it was really cool he
we Jennifer Jason Lee and I were giving
him an award for costume costume design
and he came up and he said you know he
funny for for all the how I'm known for
my the style of my movies and what it
looks like he not not one of my movies
has ever garnered in a nomination for
costumes and he lean in and he said but
we own
Halloween you're not going to have a
more fun time than you have on a
Tarantino show that's a wild ass
circus we finished the show in two
Austin we've been working for three
months four months I don't know you the
next thing I know he wants to do like
three weeks of this car stuff and he
didn't want to do any CGI or anything so
it's going to be old school d i driven
cars all my life as a kid I won a World
Championship on a race car I can do
anything you want in the car a month
maybe we were up there and Zoe Bell's on
the hood of the car at one point you
know we're doing 80 90 mes an hour and
you're on this little two-lane highway
whoop-de-do so the camera car is here
you I can't be behind the camera car I
got to be over here for the shot so I'm
now in the oncoming Lane so you're
closing off all
entrances for a let's say a 3 Four Mile
Run one day I get the okay and okay KT
bringing a hill let's go and I said
everything shut off yeah everything's
shut off we come down the road and I
don't know what happened I can't
remember what happened I either saw
something or felt something boom I just
boy man I just slammed the brakes on and
came guy goes by about 50 m an hour the
other way in the lane I was in we just
pulled over sitting there for a second
took the keys out of the car see you
[Music]
tomorrow give me that guitar
music time's
over who
whoa John the hangman Ruth there's a
cool doll on him quen had written
something that he wanted to do a reading
of sure that' be a fun day we do that
but the next thing I know is like kind
of like the whole day and it's like
feels more like a rehearsal than a read
through and it's like okay well we're
going to do it again
tomorrow I got nothing to do sure and
now we're halfway through the second and
then I begin to hear the Bo and wait wa
what did you just say and I'm talking I
think it was wal and gogs and he yeah
we're going to do a we're going to do a
reading in front of some people I said
oh oh okay he probably wants to see has
somebody he wants to have somebody see
this and say you know just and then the
next day we show up and it's it's at the
I think it's called the ace theater or
something and it's like 12200 people so
it's the reading in front of this
audience and he said yeah yeah
yeah then I just said okay so this is
now a play so I said so bring it all
down about about a third and he said
just about a third yeah I said got it I
said when he's dead I said what I just
I'll lay on the floor or something he
said but that was where it started and
then a couple months later I guess I
didn't know I thought that was just
something he wanted to do to maybe he
wanted to do it as a play then we going
to do the movie and and then okay and he
wanted me to play the part so I said
okay great wouldn't transporting her be
easier if she were dead well no one said
the job was supposed to be easy and why
is her hanging proper so important to
you let's just say I don't like cheating
a hangman he got to make a living too I
got bored with myself in a take one day
on death Death Proof I'm reading this
Soliloquy of some kind to this girl and
I started feeling like doing like John
Wayne sort of a bad John Wayne and my
book that's no good I figured he was
just GNA start all right cut it shut up
I can't take I said yeah that's the way
I was hoping and he said okay great now
that's stay right there and go back to
the be and he want and I did the whole
thing like that then he said now just
take the first third of it and there
said if we're out of film he said throw
some film in the camera it's like that's
sort of what it's like working with him
and so this character John Ruth sort of
had some of that to him in the reading I
had done some of that then when it came
time to do it he said okay now drop that
and just do your thing Lucky
Devil right that's awful interesting
bravado but he was a very you know the
character was very tired he was he's
been up and he was on edge he should
have listened to himself even more than
he did both hate f- a I think and uh
Death Proof are going to be movies that
are some of the ones that are more
looked at um 20 years from
now I got a fourman team here Rick if I
need more than that I got to get it
approved and you know I I I got to look
after my dudes hey I did have the great
pleasure of he called up he said I want
you to read something I went over and
read Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
sitting there in his in his Hollywood
Lair he just loves the history of
everything in Hollywood and I like that
when I said I don't know if there's
anybody left alive who can appreciate
this as much as me and he said I know as
he wrote in this dedication in the book
it was a lot drawn from some
conversations that we' had about my
relationship with my stuntman and in one
in particular there was a relationship
my dad had with a stuntman her when Neil
a lot of true things there and those
shows that I'd done my dad had done and
stuff that Quenton gets a kick out of
just what what he's able to do take
things and turn them on our head and
then as the night we you know we had a
couple drinks and night went on I think
DiCaprio came over that night and maybe
Brad Pit and probably 3 4:00 in the
morning all right good night I got to go
on the way out he says oh yeah and I
want you to play Randy I said Randy
who's Randy he said this St coordinator
I said I never even saw okay I'll be
there for Randy he's something
[Music]
else you said you loved my mother and
that I
did my River Lily who knew all the words
to every song that came over the radio I
mean look when I saw ego The Living
Planet I said well that's going to be
tough to say no to I didn't want to
wreck that uh what was going to be a
franchise I'd done things at Disney's
where I'd done you know as it were part
one part two part three they had done
real well in the first one I said I
don't want to come in here
and put an end to this thing you know
you want to make it
go Larry you drove your Porsche here
tonight didn't you yeah now how would
you like to trade that Porsche for a
mint condition
1952 Mickey Manel rookie card I know
you've always wanted one is this thing
real oh
yes it's a deal a deal I thought so
Santa Claus is one of my favorite
characters ever it was so big in our
household my father's presentation of it
as a mystery I infused that greatly with
Chris Columbus who is absolutely
fabulous guy I'm very very proud of that
Santa Claus you know I read some things
about it were you know a nice pat on the
back is Kurt Russell the best Santa
Claus ever on film and I thought yeah he
is you want to see Santa Claus that's
the real Santa Claus there's no
to it he's a real per he was a real
person he was a saint he was a real man
there's a certain amount of respect and
fear that children automatically have of
him it's so fascinating I was in full
regalia there and some kids would once
in a while come by and from a distance
they're staring at you and I like come
on up right as they got closer they yeah
do that it's like yeah when Santa Claus
comes around drops off pres you better
your ass better be in bed
asleep so I felt like this is a great
character to play a great sweet
wonderful saint of a man who is a real
person it's not it's not a it's not a
it's not a comic book character he he
been around longer than
[Music]
anything why do you know more than the
finest physicists geologists and
zoologists on Earth Earth don't know
more but I got a good idea about what's
going
on didn't do enough about that when I
had the chance figure on making up for
that
now or die in the trying the show is
about the people that are having to now
deal with the fact that there are these
monsters it's happening it's it's it's
happening and you go back in the history
of the lore of Godzilla Mothra King Kong
this is much more about dealing with the
people who are generationally connected
and it was a casting idea which was
never before had two known actors father
and son played the same person they
approached Wyatt and myself once we
clicked to the casting idea and we said
okay let's talk about it then it begin
the hard the heavy lifting of what do
you okay what's what are we going to do
with him that's what you see is this
unfolding mystery
of this guy who should be 93 94 95 years
old what happened here and now we're now
we're answering that question this is
about the people that are you know
living with the aftermath living with
what's next we thought yeah you know
look can we make this world a uh a good
Adventure drama and can this character
be a good strong part of that so we
Chase Godzilla then what more people die
we can't stop him stop
him Jesus Kate I'm trying to help him
because we're playing the same person we
never work together so I had a day off I
was thinking about going hitting golf
balls or something well you know what
I'll go see what Wyatt's doing so I went
down there and and it was a fight
sequence and I'm suddenly realizing yeah
this is the execution this is where the
rubbers get in the road this is what the
audience is going to see and I need to
see this I need to see what he's doing
whatever he sets in motion I'm I'm going
to have to continue if he decides to
start start playing things like that
okay well later on in life maybe it's
not that much maybe it's not that big
but I'm going to have to do a little of
it too and I was found myself watching
this actor instead of my son and saying
this guy's good man this guy's really
good it reminded me of what we had to
constantly be aware of which is this is
not father son this is the same person
and it wasn't until recently somebody
said you know we've looked around and
there that's never been done before for
us that was the fun that we had with it
you know it's real easy with Wy it's fun
and it's easy thanks for watching this
for however long you did uh I hope you
check out Monarch I think it's worth
checking out on apple plus oh guys out
out out out out